I'm a queen wildcat you're playing queen
whatever you want to be but key question
how did you hone your queen craft they
asked me to be a queen us okay perfect
and then when they told me she can
transform and be whatever she wants to
be I'm like that's who I am
anyways I mean I changed my look every
day one day I might have curly hair you
let like if you were gonna meet our
queen in real life let's roleplay the
situations already been thinking about
it okay cuz I I know she wants to see me
so we're going to [ __ ] Empire after
day it's made a queen of central office
she's let me you're having tea yes we're
having seen what she you surfing ah I'm
gonna be drinking me some some probably
submit because I like to keep it men
will be having conversation first off
I'm gonna be asking the Queen imma be
like what's it like being on money
though how does that feel
are you a little upset that they use an
older picture sometimes as opposed to a
younger picture like I'm gonna be asking
a lot of personal questions you wonder
what's going on behind closed doors
I don't care what you got going on
behind closed doors I want to know like
was she wearing that's cute
what's going on to your bedroom is your
business I think take it to the bedroom
where did you say behind the door I want
see it behind the door it's fun time
look like you trying to get behind a
door with me you like yeah I'm
officially straight
welcome welcome plot spoiler guys when
you see like a review team you singing
it yeah you know I'm working on an album
now shut up yeah granted most of this
album has already happened in my hand
but that's how it starts it all starts
in here and then it comes out there and
I've been talking to people if you hurt
my audio book you heard at the end of
the audio book there is a song that I
sang and this is before I took vocal
lessons and I got nominated for a Grammy
not for that song but for the book and I
didn't even know you could get nominated
for reading into a tape recorder but you
can so I'm gonna see what happens it
might be really great okay well I'm
already living flat Carly beaming over I
would you know I'm trying to get her on
a couple of tracks now you'll crush him
like a movie - is Batman and I didn't
realize it was possible to can't see an
action figure or a Lego figure until I
watched this cuz Batman is hunky yeah
Batman is a beefcake like luggage carts
have got abs yeah you got abs and all
that you know he backed me he worked out
he got money he can't afford the payment
so what'd you do with that money as he
tried to entrap him into your like Webb
know what Queen whatever it would nabhi
is trying to do is not entrap him it's
her Webb she is trying to encourage him
to merge his kingdom with her kingdom so
that we all could be happy that's all we
ever trying to do you mean always
thinking y'all trying to be trapped it's
like the
and nobody tell the truth because he
famously come out and said you got crush
on Brad Pitt so who after Batman was no
Brad Pitt had autumn kids and I didn't
say let's be honest let's be honest I
never said I had a crush on him I bet he
was hollering at me in the elevator and
said if he's single ending here and I'm
single in the year you see what we can
do and then I did my research and I was
like oh he's got a lot of kid that's not
gonna work for me
no no because I want to be number one
mm-hmm you know I want to be spoiled I
want to be you know number one and you
are number one yeah I'm by myself but
yeah I'm number one to me he's got your
eye on right now and nobody know who my
eyes is looking at you what I've learned
over the last year 2018 is you know men
are very afraid of women and know what
they want that's what I mean that's what
I've like no what I have what I have
devised is the plan of if I see
something I like I say well you cute
that isn't out she trade talked about
young people slide into DMS quite
regularly
you know what Drake slid it to my DM
where happy was I had seen him like a
few days later he's like yo you didn't
respond to my D and I was like well I
even though you followed me he was like
well I just want to know if you want to
be in my music video and I was like oh
okay it's like did his music video and I
thought oh maybe something might happen
you know maybe you know I was like so
you gonna take me to dinner so I'm like
what's nothing he's like yeah we can eat
dinner and then I've never heard from
him again
and that's because I was being thirsty
see that's my fault
that's my fault I should have been like
I see if I could be in the funky video
what do you do
his daddy hit me up though and I turned
his dad down so you know I might end up
being dragged stepmom aha here at
glamour we have a blend out building
campaign where we're trying to like a
radical online hate and you said before
you love the fact you're making money
out your bullies from school which we
love yeah over here I'm making money off
the bullies ah ah yeah which is great
thank you thank you buddy
you are free publicity what would you
want to say to them thank you then Wes
from junior high elementary all the
people that make fun of me was mean to
me I want to say thank you because you
molded me and made me strong enough to
deal with artists wonderful success that
I mean
rolling around there thank you it's all
to all the current haters and the people
that can't stand me and say I'm annoying
you know you can't stand my voice and I
get on your nerves
thank you for feeling something because
that means I'm doing my job if I still
get my check [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]